[Music]
hi everyone I'm Steve Brennan from the
University of Washington and this is a
new video lecture series on the Fourier
transform and wavelets this is gonna
follow chapter 2 of our new book
data-driven science and engineering by
myself and Nathan Koontz and you can
find all of the code and lecture
material online at data book UW comm and
you can also find it in the the comments
and the links below ok so I'm really
excited to talk about the Fourier
transform because this is one of the
most important and ubiquitous
transformations in all of mathematical
physics and engineering ok and if you go
back through the history of science most
of our major breakthroughs started with
a coordinate system or a coordinate
transformation that made our world make
more sense that made physics simpler in
some way and so the Fourier transform is
another coordinate transformation that
is particularly useful for for
representing data and images for
representing the solution of partial
differential equations and I'm gonna
walk you through all of the different
well not all of lots of the different
uses of this Fourier transform kind of a
mathematical theory of the Fourier
transform how to compute it in MATLAB
and in Python with the fast Fourier
transform the FFT and we're also going
to talk about the history and kind of
how this was derived so Fourier in the
early 1800s derived the Fourier
transform and the Fourier series in
particular as a way of approximating
solutions of partial differential
equations so he was particularly
interested in the heat equation so
imagine that I have some rectangular
piece of metal and this has some
temperature distribution maybe U as a
function of x and y and time in two
dimensions U is the temperature
everywhere in space and time then this
would be governed by the heat equation
which is a partial differential equation
u sub t the partial derivative of U with
respect to time is a positive constant
times the laplacian operator of u so
this is the
second partial derivative of U with
respect to X plus the second partial
derivative of U with respect to Y in two
dimensions and so what Fourier did he
didn't just write down the Fourier
transform for no reason he discovered
that the Fourier transform is a
coordinate transformation that
essentially diagonalizes this laplacian
operator in the heat equation so what he
showed was that this this operator this
laplacian has eigenvalues and
eigenfunctions just like other linear
operators do and the eigen functions are
sines and cosines with a particular
frequency determined by the boundary
conditions and the geometry of this this
object and the corresponding eigenvalues
are those spatial frequencies so for you
derived the Fourier transform
specifically to make the heat equation
simpler by transforming it into an
eigenvector eigenvalue coordinate system
okay and since then it's been used for
all kinds of applications in image
compression and solving other partial
differential equations in fact we've
actually seen that the singular value
decomposition from chapter 1 of our book
can be thought of as a data-driven
fourier so SVD is kind of like
data-driven extension of the fast
Fourier transform or the FFT ok so we've
already seen coordinate transformations
before in Chapter one with the SVD this
is kind of a generalization of the FFT
and now we're gonna go back and talk
about the more fundamental and older and
more ubiquitous Fourier transform ok
good so the Fourier transform is also I
think very important because it changed
our view of mathematics in general this
idea that you can take an arbitrary
function I'll just draw kind of a
function here so you can take an
arbitrary function let's just draw this
kind of pointy hat function and you can
approximate this by a sum of sines and
cosines of increasing frequencies so if
this function is defined on some domain
I can approximate it by a sum of sines
and cosines of increase
singly high frequencies so that's that's
one maybe now I say I'm gonna have a
higher frequency sign something like
that and so on and so forth and you can
keep adding these up it's gonna get a
little harder for me to draw this but
I'll try and so on and so forth okay so
this function you can approximate as a
sum of increasingly high frequency sines
and cosines okay and so this idea of
function approximation is one of the
really really important aspects of the
Fourier transform and of wavelets okay
this laid the foundation for our
understanding of function spaces like
the hilbert space which was pivotal in
our understanding of quantum mechanics
this idea that these or these these
sines and cosines in fact form an
orthogonal basis for the space of
possible functions so all of these kind
of functions that I could draw can be
represented in this basis of sines and
cosines so just like in a vector space
you might have your X and your Y
coordinates which form a basis for
two-dimensional vector space your sines
and cosines form a basis for function
space okay so that was really important
in this derivation and understanding of
Hilbert spaces which have been really
really foundational for our modern
understanding of mathematical physics
okay
so fast forward 200 years now we have
the fast Fourier transform okay so now
we have the fast fourier transform this
was developed relatively recently
okay the fast fourier transform or the
FFT this is how you compute a fourier
series
efficiently on a computer so this has
been absolutely central in how we
analyze and process data that we collect
so for example audio sequences images
videos these are all compressed and
represented efficiently using fast
Fourier transforms so pretty much all of
our modern digital communication is
built on the fast Fourier transform you
wouldn't be able to send pictures or
audio clips or really anything
efficiently we wouldn't be able to have
satellite communicate
if it wasn't for the fast fourier
transform so this really is one of the
absolute most important algorithms ever
developed and it's still important today
and I'm going to tell you all about it
so we're gonna walk through the fast
Fourier transform the Fourier series the
analytical Fourier transform and
wavelets we're going to code up examples
of how to solve partial differential
equations in matlab in Python we're also
going to use it for function
approximation for image compression for
audio compression for denoising so I'm
really excited to tell you about this
this is going to be one of the most
powerful tools in your arsenal
especially when you're working with data
alright thank you